interesting skirmish still unfolding
between the nfl and the nfl players
association as it relates to the issue
of participation in voluntary offseason
workouts and the ultra superficial view
on this that i've seen so many people
who don't follow this closely articulate
is well why does any of it matter it's
voluntary well it matters because
everybody always shows up because that's
just the way it is i remember a time 20
years ago where some teams would have 50
participation they all have 100 or
pretty damn close to it now this is part
of the effort to get yourself ready for
the season if you take it seriously
you're there guys aren't sitting at home
eating pork rinds and watching bowling
on tv they're working out and it makes
sense
for a variety of different reasons to
work out at the team facility this year
ostensibly because of lingering concerns
regarding the pandemic
the nfl pa has recommended to its teams
that players not show up and so far
three teams out of 32
have issued statements that they're not
going to be there seahawks broncos and
the one that surprised me the most for
reasons we'll discuss the tampa bay
buccaneers chris we've
touched on this issue from time to time
right i'm going to give you my blanket
take yeah and then i'll throw it to you
yeah cool i don't think this has
anything to do with the pandemic i just
don't and i support the nfl pa as much
as anyone and i think that there's an
unequal bargaining power and i
understand why they have a hard time
getting the best possible deal because
they won't miss game checks and the
owners will gladly shut it down and that
inequality makes it harder and harder
for the union to get the best deal and
they're always operating with one arm
behind their back and actually do pretty
damn well considering that limitation
but in this case in this instance i
think this is about protecting the jobs
of the veterans who run the union they
don't want the young cheap guys to show
up this year of all years with a 25
million reduction where the cap would
have been and prove themselves and
potentially take their jobs i think
that's what this is about oh well i mean
i don't think that's a crazy thought i
don't i think that's probably part of
the equation definitely i mean all right
here's the first part that i think like
we got to hit on here with this you know
for from the player's perspective
because i think there is fault here with
both sides and and you know you kind of
touched on it a little bit but the first
thing like i'd ask you mike just with
this conversation like where wha well
what's the nfl like you know the one
thing you hear and you see a few quotes
from a few different players like what's
the nfl's plan you know what what what
were they gonna do to keep these guys
safe continually through otas and
everything like that were they gonna
continue to test these guys on a daily
basis and do all that stuff i think
that's the first thing like i don't know
if i ever heard anything like that to
where we got guys that opted out last
year because of coven so wait let me
come back even now
oh wait kova's still really
relevant in our society and the numbers
are probably higher now than they were
like this time of the year last year and
they are i agree okay so like so hey
wait i tried to avoid it last year but
let me come back into the lion's den and
just say the hell with it this year and
go for it there there has to be a better
plan i think set forth at least from my
perspective here from the to the nfl to
the players too here
well
the the the reason that i have a an
issue with that yeah
my issue is that if this really is about
covent right and guys are really
concerned about it and you talked last
year on multiple occasions about the
fact that players yeah i know this part
don't care and only 70 out of 2 000
opted out
but
if if you got a concern about covert
right now
there's there's a thing you can do
uh to address your concern yeah get
vaccinated right far more immediate than
worrying about the quality of the
protections at
the team facility get yourself
vaccinated and i think that's part of
this now
look one of the things that the nfl
showed that it was able to do
during the season last year
was was put safeguards in place even if
guys get the virus away from work
they were able except for tennessee
early in the season baltimore middle of
the season brown's end of the season
where they all had outbreaks for one
reason or another they were able to keep
it under control and i continue to
believe that nfl facilities are going to
be safer than going to the local planet
fitness nothing against the local plan
of fitness but at least there are
specific stringent safeguards that we
know that the nfl can put in place so i
mean the bottom line is
the players
association wants all players to choose
not to show up for the voluntary portion
of the offseason program and they've
been pushing and building in that
direction for weeks now yesterday came
the memo to the players recommending
they don't show up and then the drip
drip drip of the three teams issuing the
statement that they're not going to be
there i'll believe it when i see it
frankly but broncos then seahawks then
buccaneers that's where we are whether
there are 29 other teams that will be
issuing similar statements
that remains to be seen chris
i i don't know whether this is to
command multiple news cycles or they're
just actively trying to recruit more
teams to sign on and they hope that as
more teams say they will they can use
that to convince more teams to follow
suit i think ultimately there will be
multiple teams that don't issue that
statement and i think that there will be
multiple players on the teams that did
issue the statement who will still show
up yeah i i mean agreed i i mean there
there's you know a lot of problems here
as far as what this does for for teams
players everything like that you know
where again
you know there's a lot of there's a lot
of areas i disagree with the nflpa on
this one i mean a lot you know again you
know i hear hey the the play last year
was as good as ever no it wasn't it was
not you know ask defensive coaches
around the nfl they'll tell you they
were behind the eight ball all year long
they felt like they never really got to
you know implement really the intricate
defenses that they wanted to because
they were always playing catch-up and
getting into basics still when it was
september and october and and issues
like that let alone mike i mean come on
we literally laughed at times about how
many people were going down and injured
early on i i hate to keep bringing that
point out but that was a real point you
know late august early september guys
were dropping like flies that wasn't
good for the league that's not good for
the players and then you know this
aspect of like
yeah this is where i can't really get my
head around it and this is where maybe
you're right about this veteran player
thing
but yeah they totally completely
have the advantage in the situation like
this over
really any player that's four years or
younger
and yeah they've been the guy the nfl
player who's played for four five years
or more they're nuanced they got a lot
of their techniques down
you know they've run every play in
football they understand all the
different defenses or offenses they got
to play
you know they don't need it as much but
like the nuances the young guy learns
being in the room with a coach and
having him speak directly to you and
being on the field with him and having
him show you little techniques and then
also being out there with other
teammates to add the competitive desire
and juices to make you you know even be
more alert and pay attention there's
nothing that can substitute for that you
can have all the damn zoom classes you
want and all that blah blah blah blah
blah you know no coach in the nfl is
going to tell you that's as effective as
players being there in person let alone
what it does i think physically to these
players too you know as far as not
preparing them to the season so i got a
lot of issues with this and i don't
really understand the hard line from the
nfl pa here and like it just seems like
there's no discussion about maybe trying
to make this work
i tried to find out what it is that the
nflpa is looking for and basically the
message was it depends which member of
veteran leadership you ask some
truly are concerned about the pandemic
okay some
are salty about the fact that the nfl
has unequal bargaining power and they're
still upset about the cba that was done
last year and they want to push back on
this idea that the owners get everything
that they want
and some like union president j.c
tretter doesn't want an offseason
program in any year so this year oh it's
the residual impact of the pandemic next
year it's something else and i think
that what they're hoping to do is if you
string together enough years without a
voluntary offseason program you
eventually just accept that that's the
way it is that that's what football is
now and i don't know that we're going to
get to that point because it's baked
into the cba it's been part of the nfl
for decades now and guys are going to
work out anyway that's an important
point unless your intent is to do
nothing from january to july you need a
place to work out and there's no better
place to work out than the facility that
you go to and if you
drop a weight on your foot and you're
out for the year or if you tear an
achilles tendon like michael crabtree
did just kind of you know doing walk
through plays remember that several
years ago you always have to brace
yourself for these odd field otas
because somebody's going to get some
serious injury that knocks them out for
the year if it happens you get your full
salary you're protected you do it on
your own somewhere the team can say up
non-football injury see you later so it
makes sense to do it
i can understand why the players
don't want to do it the veteran players
especially because it does give younger
cheaper players a chance to to take
their jobs and and just because we've
gone through that crush folks of teams
getting under the salary cap
they're still always looking especially
in a year like this for more cap space
that they can create so if you have the
full off-season program and that young
guy who signs after the draft for a
minimum salary if that guy shows that he
can be trusted come week one and you've
got a guy making six or seven million
who's the starter at the right guard
position but they really believe in this
guy who came in for the off-season
program who showed what he can do who
showed how he develops in the pre-season
who's ready to go and we can save six
and a half million dollars that's right
are you kidding me they they don't care
about the human they care about the
football player and they'll pull one out
and they'll put another one in
especially if they think they can save
over six million dollars in cash and cap
space that's the way the business works
so if you shut off the opportunity for
the young guy to prove himself
the veteran is protected it's a totally
valid point because you're right when in
that situation that you're explaining
right there okay we have no otas no
minicamp all that all right great we
show up for training camp and yeah there
might be that young player that you're
talking about that's got potential and
all that you know fighting it out with a
veteran player for a certain position
and
yeah there might not be enough time in
training camp to prove that he can be
trusted or be that guy you know otas and
and those mini cams they do have value
into that you know they jump start kind
of the thought for training camp oh wait
i mean hey we had 12 we had 15 practices
we saw this guy at safety already you
know yeah he's a rookie but man we think
we can start first day of training camp
we're gonna throw them out there to be a
starter instead of like okay the
opposite of that is hey we didn't
practice at all i don't know what this
guy's about hey let's just throw our
veteran in he's not we don't love him
but we trust him he knows what he's
gonna do
and you know here we are two three weeks
in the training camp and that young
player still trying to figure out his
way and doing that and never gets that
opportunity to really impress or prove
to the coach he is that guy so there is
you know definite reality to what you're
talking about and that just totally
favors the veteran players it does and
that's where you know i i it's wrong i
mean mike here here's something like
you know
one the first thing i want to say is
is there any part of you that thinks
maybe the nfl is like
cool with this not happening this year
the roster bonuses and all that even
though if you're on zoom and anything
like that can you still obtain them that
way i guess that's the first thing i
wanted to ask
you know last year when there was no
voluntary on-field off-season program
everyone who was due to make the workout
bonus based upon 90 percent right
participation in the program got it this
year if they have it you gotta show up
gotta get it okay i just wanna the union
the union isn't pushing
aggressively the guys with the workout
bonuses to not show up for example i was
told last night teams like the bills and
the packers they're not getting the big
squeeze because they have so many guys
with workout bonuses now now look it
creates competitive
realities for the teams that do show up
and if you're the packers and you're
showing up the other three teams in your
division may more may be more likely to
show up too it has a it has a domino
effect but
yeah guys have money that is tied to
showing up aaron rodgers has 500 000.
right now he's making and a half million
but that half million is for showing up
for the offseason workout program and
it's still a half million i don't care
how much money you have exactly half a
million still a half million right you
think he's going to stand down and let
jordan love get first team reps
throughout the off-season and give up
the 500 000 and also go along with the
union that he's still pissed off at
right sorry london from last year when
they did the cba and he was the packers
player rep and he eventually said i'm
out i'm done i don't like what you guys
are doing you think he's going along
with him now hell no no absolutely not
i mean most importantly i mean the 500
000 like you said that that's real i
don't care how much money you have and
then you know the jordan love aspect is
real too like for anybody that's in that
particular situation
you know added to it like but what like
i i don't know like if i'm a quarterback
in today's nfl i'm like sorry nflpa i'm
going in to go visit with coach gruden
and i'll be there tomorrow and the next
day and the next day because guess what
i want to be the best player i can
possibly be and that to help that happen
is to be with my coach so he can coach
me in person you know there's something
to that he can put me through drill work
and stay on me and really seem see me in
person with his eyes and tweak me and
all those type of things that's getting
lost and that's where you know i wonder
how this is gonna work i do you know i
mean listen we hear seattle like like
russell wilson you're not gonna show up
to the facility i mean maybe that's a
bad example of a guy this year but you
know what i'm saying that type of guy
where drew lock like there you know the
broncos like what you're not gonna show
up and get coached by some of these guys
in a huge year of your career and then
try to get in like hey wide receivers
why don't you come too
you know that's where i just don't even
know how the players some of them can
get behind that if you want to be great
a couple years ago in the aftermath of
the colin kaepernick situation and the
national anthem kneeling there was a
realization that the players have a lot
more power than they are willing to use
and one of the points i made was if you
want to show your collective power you
do get together and you say off season
program we're not going to be there the
problem is pulling it off and the way to
pull that off is to get all the
quarterbacks to sign on because good
luck having football practice if you
have no quarterbacks there but you're
not gonna pull that off the veteran
wants to be there the young guy who's
trying to develop wants to be there and
we haven't talked about this angle yet
this applies to the seahawks the broncos
and the buccaneers whoever is speaking
now whoever is supplying their voice to
this desire to stay away they're not
speaking for all the draft picks and all
the undrafted free agents who will be
joining the team in the next two or
three weeks right those guys don't even
know what team they're going to be
assigned to and i guarantee you this i
talked to people about it last night i
haven't written this yet specifically
you know what's going to happen
when it's time to sign the undrafted
free agents
the teams are going to say we want a
commitment from you before we offer you
this contract that you're showing up
yeah for the off-season program you're
going to be here right are you going to
be here you know it's hard to make this
team you want a chance to make this team
you got to be here are you going to be
here if not we're going to sign this
other guy instead you're going to have
commitments extracted unofficial verbal
non-enforceable but enforceable
commitments that these guys are going to
show up then where are the veteran
players if they're home
but the young guys are there that might
be the hurrying favor with the coaching
staff that's how it all collapses see
the league i'm told the league thinks
this is one of the best developments
that has happened in years as it relates
to labor relations because it's going to
reinforce the point from 1987 that we
talked about not that long ago when your
dad was part of the group that went on
strike and strike didn't hold together
this is going to be a reminder that work
stoppages don't work from the player's
perspective yeah well i mean they yes i
think there's reality to that mike i
mean all right so at a base level here
we still the nfl are you are you happy
with their plan though like do you think
they need to have more of a plan for the
players to come back and feel safe
because i think even with all the stuff
we're talking about in the nflpa
i do think there has to be something
more done there right to make the
players feel good i mean am i wrong am i
missing something well
i i look i don't know anything about the
specifics other than go get the vaccine
yeah but beyond that if they just do
what they did last year i just assume
they're going to do what they did last
year
on the way in i haven't heard
why why but why would you not i i i i
think at a minimum the nfl's got to test
these guys every day just like they they
would like to football season right
right
and and i i i do think
this deeper back and forth about getting
vaccinated is part of it too they're not
going to mandate it but they're looking
for ways to encourage the players to
choose to do it on their own and if they
don't do it now they're going to they're
going to be put in a box when training
camp and the regular season roll around
because it's going to be like the nba
where if you get it you have lesser
restrictions if enough guys on your team
get it you have lesser restrictions
collectively so there's gonna be peer
pressure right to get it right and i
think for the same reason
that
we talked last year over and over again
how these guys really don't care about
cove they think they're impervious to it
they think it won't make them sick
i i really do think that
you just stick a needle in my arm look
at all the other stuff you stick in me
look at all these drugs i take you want
to give me a vaccine give me the vaccine
if it allows me to have a normal life
during football season if it allows me
to have to tiptoe on eggshells around
the facility every day i'm at work and i
can just focus on my work then just give
me the damn vaccine yeah i i think
that's the core of this they want they
want guys to choose to get vaccinated
but i still think the pushback i really
don't think it's about collective covet
concern i think it's about remember the
guys who run the union are typically
veteran players i think it's about
protecting those jobs in a year where
the salary caps 25 million lower than it
was supposedly well if it is it's just
it's so selfish and so small-minded and
ridiculous that those veteran players
are steering that ship in in this
direction you know because at once you
know of course they were young players
and needed those reps and that help and
all that stuff and you're doing you know
at a again at a base level you're doing
an injustice to the whole football
league there's no doubt about that i'm
so sick of like i don't want to hear any
more but they think we don't need it i
think we don't need that generally
it's just a good lazy thought it's a
great lazy thought like yeah we don't
need it yeah okay right you don't need
it that's like not reality you do need
it football is a different sport you
know training yourself to be healthy
like we've talked about we've had these
discussions and the medical science is
starting to show like you got to be out
there on the field go putting yourself
in these awkward positions conditioning
yourself for what you're going to have
to do
i mean
you know again like this goes for any
any profession in life mike i mean right
i mean when you were a lawyer were you
just like well
i'm not really gonna get into law here
or anything i'm gonna take five or six
months off i'll read a little bit every
now and then i'll read a little bit and
i'll i'll i'll come back a fresher
lawyer in september oh yeah will you
good luck okay that doesn't work in any
profession that's it's a bullcrap you
know stance from the players and if i
was a player and a player rep i'd be
pissed off right now and yelling about
this and trying to make waves about it
think about this chris and this is why i
was stunned that the buccaneers were one
of the teams to issue the statement that
they're going to boycott the voluntary
off-season program last year
june or july time frame
the nflpa issued a statement
an advisory a recommendation to the
players that were working out on their
own stop it
until training camp over right quit
working out together and that was
directed
at the
buccaneers because
tommy what was tom and his band of merry
men doing at that high school in tampa
they were getting together and they were
working out and here's the concern i
have right because i first of all i
don't think this is going to fly you
told them last year don't work out on
your own and they did this year you're
telling them don't go to the team
facility and work out and you really
think they're not going to i think they
eventually will but until then do you
really think that tom brady and his
teammates are going to do nothing yeah
so now here's what you're doing and
think about this young buccaneers
receiver when you get the phone call
from tom brady putting the squeeze on
you to go show up at the local high
school field
instead of going to the team facility
when you step on a rock the wrong way
when you're running full speed and you
blow out your acl is tom paying your
salary this year because the team sure
as hell isn't going to this year if you
deliberately choose not to work out
there to go work out with tom on the
side
because they can do it every year tim
teams typically won't do it because they
they don't want to punish a guy for
staying in shape but for something like
this
to prove a point to score points in that
back and forth that is incessant between
union and league if tom brady convinces
you to go play over here you better get
him to give you something in writing
that he's going to pay your salary
because you got a place where you can go
and have your salary protected it's the
team facility so unless the buccaneers
okay because i and i'm not i i'm gonna
be relentless about this if we see the
same videos we saw last year of tom
brady and his teammates at some extra
separate facility working out together
when they could be just at the team
facility doing it it's a stupid clumsy
way that puts guys salaries for the year
at risk if they get injured working out
on their own yeah no it is i mean
there's a lot more risk and everything
you do that way i mean there really is i
mean you kind of hit it already but if
you were worried about coving and all
those things too i mean being at the
facility still would be the best uh you
know
avenue for all of that
hey i mean hey we have a hundred water
bottles so nobody has to share it you
know hey we have had a service in here
to clean things and do all that where
you know you go to just a local field
it's it's a crap show i mean it's just
you know guys hanging out in the field
who knows you know what's clean what's
dirty whatever else so i mean i think
there's a lot of things that
don't make sense about this for the
players in a big way i really don't and
i don't think it's good for the players
and and then and just so anybody you
know is doubting us out there or
questioning mike and i are very pro
player i mean we are pro player almost
all the time and we are arguing against
this because we don't think this is good
for the players ultimately it's it's not
going to help them out
and and i don't know
how
i i want to be careful i
but
i've made my point clear
to the union and i say hey don't get me
wrong here i i think that you guys
deserve
better terms more money more i'm always
on your side but on this one i don't get
it i don't see it because i don't see it
working and at the end of the day it's
going to be more power for the league
when this thing crumbles because i think
it will eventually crumble for the
reasons that you and i have have
discussed they're going to have a hell
of a time holding this together because
once those young players are on board
they're going to show up they're going
to get their reps and then you're going
to see the possibility that owners
executives coaches maybe even it may
they may be more likely to dump that
expensive veteran and go with a young
player just to prove the point that we
need a robust off-season program so we
can have our guys as best prepared as
they can be for the upcoming football
season so i just i just don't i don't
think
that this is going to work and it's
better to not do something that you
think isn't going to work than just
blindly rush into something that has the
chance of imploding i think this thing
has a real chance of imploding on the
union chris yeah i i uh agree agree and
yeah just i don't think it's helpful to
the players or the base base level i got
nothing more to say about it so if
you're good i got one more thing yeah i
got one more thing to say
i i do want to know where tom brady
stands on this because it was last year
when he was organizing these workouts at
the height of the concerns about the
pandemic months before vaccines were
available and he pulled the the only
thing we have to fear is fear itself
where's that mindset now when you know
when you know that the guys are going to
work out
where why why why are you afraid to go
into the team facility when they've
proven
that that they can keep those facilities
cleaner and keep the guys safer than
they're going to be anywhere else i
hated the argument last year from the
college football coaches that we need to
go forward with the football season
because the players are safer here than
they would be anywhere else i hated that
because it was driven by the desire of
the coaches to make their money but you
know what they got a point yeah the nfl
players are going to be safer in their
team facilities based upon how they ran
them last season than they're going to
be anywhere else
and if i'm wrong prove me wrong no mike
i agree with you totally i mean that was
one of the things i was saying yeah you
go to the practice field it's just a
bunch of guys that are messy and dirty
and who knows what happens the facility
you got somebody watching over things
and things are done professionally yeah
it's definitely the safer place all
together let alone like you talked about
it saves the player contractually if an
issue does happen oh i broke my ankle
wait it was here at the facility i was
working out for the football team okay
no problem at all oh you did it at
hillsborough high school down the street
wait well i don't know we're not sure if
we're happy about that why were you
practicing on that field you know it's
not safe it's uneven it's got divot
holes everywhere i mean yeah there's
you're opening up a a a litany of issues
uh if you're a player you know playing
this game
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports